Jonas is with us to start this hour off
in Georgia hi Jonas how are you I'm
doing well are you doing these better
than I deserve what's up well first off
I just want to say I appreciate the time
and answer on the hold for me so I'm 22
years old and I'm recently engaged and
me and my fiance found out that we are
expecting have a baby in the early part
of October so I guess my question stems
from over the past few years I've
started trust or savings and I have
about $30,000 saved up I didn't know if
now would be a good compost wasn't
started looking to buy a home we have
the option to stay with family um at a
much lower rent I didn't know if it
would be wise to stay with family in
terms I don't want calls me just
distress amongst us which we all get
along that's not an issue but um if that
would be wise or if we should look into
getting the apartment and then continue
in to save um and the meantime until we
can store our home yeah when are you
getting married
it'll be on June 27 okay and I would get
an apartment that you move into
immediately following that and and then
a year later I would think about looking
for a house but I would rent for at
least a year and let's get baby here and
baby and mommy are okay let's learn to
be a household be a family let's learn
to pay bills in that environment run a
budget in that environment stay out of
debt clean up any debts she's got it if
she doesn't have any pile up cash and
have an emergency fund beyond the
emergency fund start saving up your down
payment you'll still only be 24 25 years
old when you buy a house mm-hmm
that's still very young a house and
you'll still be just fine so you would
recommend that we don't move in with
anything no I would not do that okay and
then stop stop just saying the reason
is real simple something happened with
my kids and my kids are slightly older
than you they would you know sometimes
come back from college graduate from
college stayed with us a few months and
then they go out on their own when they
go out on their own and they're paying
their own bills the electricity gets cut
off if they don't pay it they're buying
their own groceries at the grocery store
they're vacuuming their own floor they
picked out their own apartment something
happened in their emotional maturity it
leapt forward and lept forward and you
guys are getting ready to be a mom and a
dad you're getting ready to have a new
marriage and you need your own place it
is going to be good for your
relationship it's going to be good for
your your the your emotional development
your maturity everything and I would beg
you to get out and get you an apartment
as a matter of fact you probably ought
to go ahead and do it now and she helps
pick the apartment that because she's
gonna move in there after you get
married and so that's probably what I
would do right now and you guys figure
this out so hey thanks for the call
there's a good rule of thumb by the way
um I always tell young couples and this
would be people under 30 or so wait a
year after you're married before you buy
I want you to buy a house well R it's
cheaper I'd read Real Estate's cheaper
than buying ren-dono shut up just wait a
year wait a year because it takes about
a year of being married to know how
close to your mother-in-law to buy
you've got to get to know each other to
make a better decision on what you buy
your the dynamics of your relationship
are going to form there's gonna be a lot
of stuff happens in that first year
for some people it's really tough here
so spend a year on your marriage not on
hanging curtains not on painting
bedrooms and doing a rehab spend a year
on your marriage and then you'll make
better decision when you buy I do want
you to buy I just don't want you to
think that buying a house is so
mandatory that you're never if you don't
do it immediately you're gonna die or
something